[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de cette
semaine voici les titres de ce vendredi
ventre 23 mars chercheurs médecins et
professionnels a réuni pendant trois
jours à l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'association
française pour la trisomie 21 organise
son colloque pour faire notamment le
point sur les progrès de la prise en
charge et de la recherche en france près
de 70000 personnes sont atteintes par
cette anomalie est génétique a dévoilé
le métier de journaliste et aider les
plus jeunes à démêler le vrai du faux la
29e semaine de la presse et des médias
dans l'école était organisée est cette
semaine dans les établissements
scolaires près de 300 écoles du
département au participer à l'événement
l'occasion de regarder de plus près la
situation des médias et des journalistes
en france est de mesurer la méfiance
qu'ils peuvent susciter avec françois
robinet directeur d'études du parcours
journalisme et monde contemporain a levé
est plus dans le reste de l'actualité
nous reviendrons sur la grève des
fonctionnaires et des cheminots jeudi un
rassemblement avait lieu à versailles ou
encore les rythmes scolaires qui font
débat à trappes
mais on ouvre cette émission avec ses
révélations du journal libération sur le
lycée militaire de saint cyr l'école
quotidien révèle dans son édition du 23
mars que des lycéennes serait soumis à
un harcèlement moral important au sein
de l'établissement par certains
étudiants masculins qui appartiendrait
aux milieux catholiques traditionnels
selon le journal ces agissements
viserait à décourager les jeunes femmes
qui souhaitent devenir officier
la ministre des armées florence parly a
réagi à cette affaire vendredi matin sur
rtl pour dénoncer des agissements
inacceptables
je vous en parlais dans les titres
mercredi 21 mars était la journée
mondiale de la trisomie 21 la maladie
est due à la présence d'un troisième
chromosome 21 qui dérégule l'expression
des gènes humains pour apprendre à mieux
connaître la pathologie l association
française pour la recherche sur la
trisomie 21 organise chaque année son
colloque la 13e
dition se déroule en ce moment à l'ufr
des sciences de la santé de l'ue vs
cuche reportage de grégory canal et la
trisomie 21 est elle une maladie rare
comment peut-on aller vers plus
d'autonomie des malades
autant de questions abordées lors de ce
13e colloque sur la maladie cet
événement sert à faire un point sur
l'avancée de la recherche mais aussi
cassé avec quelques codes et idées
reçues
l'objectif c'est de réunir les personnes
qui travaillent autour de de la trisomie
pendant longtemps durant deux ou trois
jours afin qu' il puisse échanger les
gens entre différentes informations dont
les objets et éventuellement nous allons
nous avons nous annoncer d'éventuelles
avancées sur leurs recherches pendant
ces trois jours à l'ufr des sciences de
la santé une vingtaine de spécialistes
se succèdent comme françois vialard
professeur à lui fait est ce qu il
dirige l'unité de recherche gamètes
implantation gestation et dans le cadre
de l'opération
la course des héros ses recherches
actuelles ont besoin de dons nous avons
aussi proposé un traitement en fait un
anténatal pour les individus qui ont une
trisomie 21 ans pour enfin les fêtes
justin trudeau 21 pour pouvoir en fait
espérer un jour contrer les les effets
délétères de cette présente troisième
chromosome 21 sur le développement
cérébral dont l'amphithéâtre de l'ue vs
qu associatif parents de malades mais
aussi personnes atteintes de trisomie 21
joël 28 ans a tout récemment sorti son
autobiographie il est important pour lui
de parler de son parcours à la fin
important pour un sel et sont pires que
nous pas comme ma vue en tout on te
soutient les combos coup de pouce
monique n'ont pas été faciles
mon nouveau affrontés avec connecter un
autre jour
ce colloque se déroule tous les ans
environ 60000 personnes vivent en france
avec une trisomie 21
cette semaine se tenait aussi la 29e
édition de la presse et des médias dans
l'école près de 300 établissements
yvelinois ont participé à l'événement
objectif faire
découvrir aux plus jeunes le monde des
médias les aider aussi à traiter les
informations qui peuvent paraître dans
les journaux sur internet ou sur les
réseaux sociaux et développer aussi leur
esprit critique et ce alors que la
méfiance envers les médias reste élevé
en france et plus généralement dans les
sociétés occidentales françois robinet
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes maître de
conférences à l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines être dire
études directeur d'études du parcours
journalisme et monde contemporain
vous organisez vous même certaines
animations pour favoriser l'éducation
aux médias récemment du côté de orléans
l'éducation aux médias est il devenu
aujourd'hui un enjeu majeur de nos
sociétés modernes
une vitalité aussi pour leur bon
fonctionnement vous diriez alors un
enjeu majeur très certainement encore
plus peut-être
ces dernières années du fait des formes
d'embrigadement qui existe sur internet
de la part de certains réseaux
extrémistes on pense voient l'extrémisme
islamiste au terrorisme ou à l'extrême
droite également du fait aussi de
l'essor très certainement du complotisme
sur ses réseaux et en même temps j'ai
envie de dire que cet enjeu n'est pas
totalement nouveau puisque l'engagement
de la société et de l'éducation sur
cette question de l'information
c'est un engagement qui est plutôt
ancien avec sa classe également
renouvelé voilà ces dernières années
parce qu'on a le sentiment qu'il ya
présentement un effort collectif plus
conséquent à produire que ce qu'on a
produit jusque là mais il faut être
assez prudent sur l'idée de devoir de la
nouveauté où il n'y en a pas forcément
et peut-être que c'est aussi un des
éléments de réflexion sur lesquelles on
pourrait s'interroger alors là tous les
efforts sont concentrés sur sur cinq
jours sur une semaine pour pour aider
les plus jeunes à mieux s'informer à
comprendre l'information alors je vais
je vais vous poser une question à
laquelle j'ai déjà la réponse mais ce
que finalement cinq 5 jours ça ça suffit
est-ce que c'est suffisant ou alors est
ce qu'on pourrait imaginer ancrée
l'éducation aux médias pleut plus
concrètement dans l'éducation nationale
peut être dès le collège où dès l'école
primaire avec un module spécial
non je crois qu'il ya plusieurs
dispositifs qui sont déjà présents qui
existent et qui soit en briques et les
uns avec les autres
cette semaine
en gros c'est une vitrine c'est une
invitation ça pour montrer comment des
partenaires du monde de l'éducation
nationale et des partenaires issus des
prophéties de la profession de
journalistes peuvent travailler ensemble
ce qu'ils peuvent essayer de partager
comment les témoignages des journalistes
sont importants pour que les jeunes
générations comprennent les modalités de
la fabrique de l'information mais il est
bien évident ce n'est pas le seul
dispositif et que cela ne peut résoudre
l'ensemble des problèmes qui se posent
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on en sait
aujourd'hui
alors justement j'allais j'allais y
venir chaque cette semaine elle prend
place aussi dans des dispositifs souvent
de plus long terme sur l'année scolaire
donc la semaine est en grande partie
porté par le clemi le clemi nationale
mia déclemy aussi régionaux qui sont
chargés de cette liaison entre les
professionnels de l'information parce
que le centre de liaison des médias
assez pour la grèce et diamants inverse
centre de liaison de l'enseignement et
des médias qui travaille à la fois au
niveau national et au niveau des
délégations en régionale et il faut
savoir que dans les établissements
scolaires ou dans les universités
sur l'ensemble de l'année d'autres
projets existent qui peuvent être des
projets à l'échelle d'une classe qui
peuvent être des projets à l'échelle
d'un établissement ont cité le festival
les médiatiques tout à l'heure avec en
plus cet objectif de l'éducation aux
médias et à l'information qui depuis lé
2013 est inscrit au socle commun de
compétences des élèves
là aussi on peut juger que peut-être ça
ne sera pas suffisant avec l'effort
collectif doit dépasser l'éducation
nationale très certainement mais qu'au
moins on sache que l'éducation nationale
et mobiliser sur cette question
ça me paraît complètement essentiel
certains comme jérôme bouvier qui est
spécialiste de ce sujet là vous
attendiez marama question apparemment
leone mais c'est un acteur important de
ce oui ces questions il a il a proposé
lui la création d'une agence nationale
de l'éducation à l'information avec des
moyens qui seraient attitré spécialement
à 7 à cette agence vous en pensez quoi
vous de créer une agence spécialisée là
dedans pour favoriser pour aller
toujours plus loin dans l'éducation aux
médias alors j'ai pas pris connaissance
de l'ensemble de l'argumentation de
jérôme bouvier sur ce sujet mais je
crois comprendre dans cette demande
c'est une demande de convergence des
efforts c'est ce que je disais un
instant les efforts de l'éducation
nationale c'est très bien c'est
essentiel c'est crucial les connexions
qu'on peut faire avec les rédactions et
les professionnels de l'information
c'est encore mieux
mais même ces demandes là ne peuvent à
eux seuls permettre à aux jeunes
générations mais aussi parfois aux
générations plus anciennes qui ont
parfois des difficultés à décrypter
l'information et qui sont parfois canton
6 50 60 ans qui peuvent se sachant
recherché
voilà sur les réseaux sociaux par les
fameuses fox news
c'est l'ensemble de la société qui doit
se mobiliser et on peut s'interroger sur
le rôle d'autres institutions par
exemple les partis politiques les
associations les journalistes qui
peuvent re tweeté de fausses
informations alors les journalistes eux
mêmes et ce que je voulais dire qu'elle
voulait assister et je pense qu'elle
rejoint le en partie le projet de jérôme
bouvier c'est cette idée de convergence
vraiment des efforts et de ne pas penser
que l'éducation nationale seuls même
avec ton actuellement des coups de mains
des journalistes ou des projets
construit avec les journées ça ne
suffira pas les familles par exemple
serait approprié l'outil presse écrite
se réapproprier collectivement la
manière dont un sujet diffusé à la
télévision ce qu'on peut en comprendre
ce qu'on peut apercevoir et de discuter
collectivement ça aussi c'est très
important excuses pour ces éventuelles
provocations mais ce que les citoyens
eux mêmes non parole à se
responsabiliser
peut-être aussi à faire attention à ce
qu'ils peuvent lire à vérifier les
informations peut être à favoriser
certains médias concède demi heure
peut-être qualité que d'autres risquent
eux aussi en tant que citoyen on n'a pas
un rôle à jouer soi-même et ne pas tout
attendre tout attendre excusez moi
plutôt de l'éducation nationale et des
professionnels de l'information
alors je sais pas si les citoyens
attendent tous des journalistes et des
enseignants mais viser aussi dans le
sens où il ya des critiques envers les
médias actuellement oui les journalistes
ce qui est sûr c'est que comprendre les
bonnes pratiques de lecteurs ou
d'internautes comment est ce qu'on
vérifie une information comment est ce
qu'on vérifie qu'une image n'est pas
truquée ou que sa légende n'est pas
fausse c'est aussi des bonnes pratiques
qui peuvent se diffuser entre groupes
d'amis au sein d'une famille et sont des
choses qui doivent se partager
collectivement
or je pense qu'aujourd'hui l'information
est un enjeu majeur pour vous pour moi
voilà enseignants chercheurs enseignants
journalistes
mais peut-être que cette idée que c'est
un enjeu majeur ce n'est pas encore
totalement partagée à l'échelle de
l'ensemble de la société
et s'il ya une sensibilité
la scion affaire c'est peut-être sur ce
sujet là et c'est au delà même des faits
qui nous tient que l'information c'est
un enjeu citoyen majeur en période
électorale comme en non électorale
puisque ça mais au coeur de l'espace
public
les sujets et les gens je les enjeux
qu'on considère comme cruciaux donc
faut-il parler aujourd'hui de
l'immigration des migrants et comment
parle-t-on pas qu'on peut légiférer déjà
sur les traits de news comme le souhaite
le gouvernement selon vous est ce que
est ce qu'on la loi ou la jouer là
dedans
alors bon je comprends le projet d'
emmanuel macron qui a été lui-même sujet
a énormément et de fausses informations
dans sur cet axe préfectorale voilà donc
je peux comprendre ce souhait je ne suis
pas sûr que ce soit vertueux au sens où
qu elle l instance légitime susceptibles
ou capable de définir la bonne
information d'identifier correctement
les sources valable le tout dans un
délai extrêmement court puisque le
projet de loi souhaite se concentrer sur
les périodes électorales et souhaite que
le jugement soit cinq semaines avant les
périodes électorales
voilà et souhaite que le juge des
référés puisse intervenir à très court
terme donc dans ces conditions là je ne
suis pas sûr que ce soit avec le
vertueux et je pense même que cela peut
éventuellement devenir liberticide pour
la liberté d'informer et la liberté
d'expression donc j'attends de voir ce
que le projet tel qu'il sera produit et
si c'est pour réclamer plus de
transparence notamment de la part des
plateformes facebook twitter qui
permettent aujourd'hui à des à des
comptes avec ceux de nîmes 2 diffusé des
fausses informations de dire des choses
interdites par la loi illégal est ce que
si c'est pour plus de transparence et
une
c'est une loi souhaitable alors je ne
sais pas si c'est un jeu de transparence
seront présents dans la loi en même
temps du côté des réseaux sociaux
facebook et twitter
est ce vraiment la transparence le
problème ou n'est-ce pas plutôt la
manière dont ces réseaux fils tout ne
filtre pas un certain nombre de
formations d'information de propos aussi
racistes sait s'il y en avait aussi la
jauge russes comment vont-ils faire pour
filtrer est-ce que c'est à twitter de
filtrer les informations à ce que
twitter est un organisme de presse aux
médias
là aussi on voit les limites du débat
je voulais juste vous poser une dernière
question sur les sur l'effet que news
elles ont pris beaucoup d'importance
aujourd'hui dans l'actualité on en
parlait énormément depuis l'élection de
donald trump notamment aux états unis
est-ce que vous avec votre regard de
chercheurs est ce que vous diriez que
c'est quelque chose d nous de nouveau
les fêtes newzoo finalement c'est un
phénomène vieux presque comme le monde
et que c'est juste que on a toujours la
tête dans l'actualité dans le présent et
qu'on n'arrive pas à se dégager
justement de ce prisme là du présent
alors dans un très court laps de temps
il ya deux éléments à mettre à mettre en
avant
le premier c'est l'idée que les fausses
informations existait effectivement
depuis des siècles on pense ou ne serait
ce que pour mon temps le début du 20e
siècle voilà les bobards les canards les
fausses informations la manipulation de
l'information finit aussi pendant les
conflits ou en période de conflit ce
n'est absolument pas un phénomène
nouveau en revanche ce qui est un fait
d' un phénomène nouveau c'est l'ampleur
de la mobilisation d'un certain nombre
de groupes pour fabriquer des
informations qui vise à nuire
avec aujourd'hui en plus la capacité à
leur donner une résonance a
exceptionnellement forte du fait de la
présence des réseaux sociaux
sinon des petites pme presque oui on est
dans une logique presque industrielle
parfois de production d'informations
pour nuire à certaines réputations la
réputation de certaines personnalités de
certains groupes de certaines
entreprises certaines associations de
certaines personnalités et cela en
revanche c'est nouveau c'est cette
efficacité que peuvent avoir ces
informations totalement fabriquées dans
un souci de nuisance et ça je pense
qu'on n'était pas du tout sur ce type de
logique il ya encore quelques quelques
décennies françois robinet restez avec
nous on passe tout de suite au résumé de
l'actualité de la semaine
l actualité marquée par un mouvement
social d'ampleur jeudi cheminots et
fonctionnaires étaient appelés à
manifester contre les différentes
réformes du gouvernement sur le
ferroviaire notamment et la fonction
publique à paris selon les premiers
chiffres d'un comptage effectué par une
collaboration entre médias près de
quarante sept mille personnes ont
manifesté un rassemblement à versailles
étaient aussi organisées à l'appel
notamment de la cgt une centaine de
personnes étaient présentes sur place
propos recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude des disques des discussions des
négociations nous on y est favorable
il ya plein de choses qui peuvent être
améliorées aide sur la logique de
supprimer 120 mille postes c'est ça
qu'ils nous préparent dont 70 mille
postes dans la fonction publique
territoriale
c'est inconcevable quand on voit
l'explosion des besoins il ya eu la
période de temps et souvent par exemple
les épisodes neigeux où tout le monde se
disait ça va pas ça va pas assez vite
mais derrière ces des moyens le problème
il est juste là dessus en fait si ça met
du temps à déneiger c'est parce qu'il
n'ya pas assez nombreux c'est très
concret c'est très basique elle la
journée de jeudi marquée aussi par la
mobilisation d'une partie des salariés
de météo-france attrape comme 29 autres
centres de prévision
en france le site de trappes va fermer
d'ici 2022 500 emplois sont ainsi
menacés et qui viendrait s'ajouter à 700
postes déjà supprimés depuis 2012 un
risque à terme pour la qualité de la
précision des prévisions au niveau local
selon les grévistes
enfin à versailles des lycéens ont
bloqué l'accès à leur établissement à
versailles donc mobilisation avec
l'appui notamment du mouvement
générations contre la plateforme
d'admission postbac harcourt sup lancé
en ce début d'année elle instaure une
forme de sélection à l'entrée des
universités selon ses opposants françois
robinet une réaction rapide sur cette
nouvelle initiative des médias qui
décide désormais de deux comtés
eux-mêmes le nombre de manifestants lors
des rassemblements
en partant du principe que les chiffres
sont trop éloignées entre forces de
l'ordre et et syndicats est ce que
finalement ça c'est pas la preuve
qu'aujourd'hui les médias sont plus qui
essentielle encore plus qui a puisque il
ya tellement d'influencés aujourd'hui
que sont les médias
on a du mal à déchiffrer le vrai du faux
et ça moi n'en moyens d'appui pour
peut-être redonner confiance dans les
médias ce qui est tout à fait de manière
de voir les choses je pense que c'est
une initiative qui va dans le bon sens
d'abord c'est l'initiative qui s'inscrit
aussi dans une logique plus large de
fact checking aujourd'hui une logique
mobilisés par de nombreuses rédactions
notamment le ps que oui pas sur les
effectifs mans où le des codex du monde
il faut merci de citer mon université et
en même temps ça m'interroge aussi ce
rôle très certainement vertueux ici de
vérification des médias interroge sur le
positionnement de la police et des
syndicats
par exemple dans le futur projet de loi
est ce que les cinq cent mille oeufs
manifestants de la cgt est ce qu'on
serait ici dans à une forme de deux
fausses informations des menaces n'est
pas grave on n'est pas en période
électorale
certes mais voyez les chiffres sont
parfois amplifier ou euphémisé pour
démontrer que une mobilisation est
d'ampleur au contraire elle est
relativement marginale et la 2s que les
totems pourra être mise en cause du coup
à travers la police écoutez mon à
l'intérieur mais en tout cas je
m'interroge et voyez ça rejoint le
propos que j'avais tout à l'heure c'est
que je pense qu'il est très très
difficile de définir très clairement ou
de trouver une instance suffisamment
légitime pour définir ce que c'est
qu'une fausse information
sauf si on considère et qu'on se
concentre sur son caractère nuisible
comme je le disais tout à l'heure mais
le gouvernement pourrait lire ici que
les chiffres de la cgt sont invisibles
pour son action la sécurité entre
l'action voilà donc du coup vous voyez
c'est tout cela est assez complexe quand
même merci françois robinet d'avoir
répondu à toutes ses questions je
rappelle que vous êtes maître de
conférences à lui vécu directeur
d'études du parcours journalisme et
monde contemporain merci à vous et bon
ok merci beaucoup dans le reste de
l'actualité cette semaine la réforme des
rythmes scolaires fait débat attrape
alors que la plupart des villes du
secteur ont décidé de revenir à la
semaine de quatre jours
trappes souhaite obtenir une dérogation
du ministère de l'éducation nationale
pour un modèle hybride 4 jours en
maternelle mais quatre jours et demi en
élémentaire une proposition que
rejettent certains syndicats et
enseignants patrick jacques de dixmude
pour les images dans le froid et sous
les fenêtres de l'inspection de
l'éducation nationale
enseignants et syndicats locaux
expriment leur désaccord
ils sont opposés au projet de la ville
de trappes sur les rythmes scolaires un
projet qui conserverait le rythme actuel
de quatre jours et demi pour les
écoliers élémentaire mais qui
basculerait à quatre jours pour les
maternelles sans rattrapage des heures
supprimées
c'est un principe d'égalité inscrit dans
la constitution donc il n'est pas a
fortiori sur un territoire comme
celui-ci acceptable que l'on diminue le
nombre d'heures d'enseignement au delà
de ça ce que nous demandons c'est le
retour à quatre jours les quatre jours
et demi sur trappe
n'ayant absolument pas fait la preuve de
leur d'être satisfaisante des rythmes
différents maternelle et en élémentaire
une première qui nécessitait l'accord du
ministère de l'éducation nationale pour
justifier cette innovation le maire de
la ville assure qu'il cherche la
meilleure solution pour les enfants est
garanti que rien n'est encore décidé
vous pourrez avoir des éléments
différents en temps et en rythmes que
par rapport aux primaires il ya des
enfants en maternelle surtout la toute
petite section qui sauront qu'ils sont
qui sont fatigués donc est-ce qu'on a
une réponse ou pas on peut pas décider
ça tout seul donc attendre la réponse du
nice pour continuer à manifester leur
opposition enseignants et syndicats
prévoit d'intervenir lors du prochain
conseil municipal mardi le ministère lui
n'a pas encore répondu à la demande de
dérogation formulées par la mairie 2
million deux cent mille euros récoltés
pour l'édition 2010 est du téléthon dans
les yvelines les chiffres définitifs de
l'opération solidaire ont été dévoilés
ce mardi les yvelines se place deuxième
derrière paris 2e
dans les départements franciliens les
plus donateurs plus de 14 millions
d'euros ont été récoltés au niveau
régional rappelez-vous sur le territoire
beaucoup de défis ont été relevés pour
cette édition du téléthon dont ce record
du
monde d'andy et cabreira davilla à saint
cyr l'école on le voit l'image 24 heures
de nage en apnée pour la bonne cause
connaissez-vous l'hôpital des nounours
la phrase peut faire sourire c'est
l'opération qui a été est organisée
jeudi à versailles par des étudiants en
médecine de l'ue vs q l'objectif montrer
aux plus petits que l'hôpital n'est pas
un endroit si dramatique grâce à leurs
doudous et leur enseigner aussi quelques
notions médicales et d'hygiène des
images de patrick jacques de dixmude ah
ben tu vois ça on va pouvoir les mettre
sur la panne de tombes d'où se balader
toute droite on va pouvoir réparer les
autres feront mais qu'arrive-t-il à
l'ila le doudou de noémie amon lorsqu
elle est il assez du vélo et les tombées
et alors qu'est ce qui se passe et il
s'est cassé la patte
si lille a s'est cassé la patte il faut
donc aller à l'hôpital pour la soigner
l'hôpital ces murs blancs ces piqûres et
ses grandes blues un lieu qui peut
effrayer les enfants et c'est pour
contrer ce sentiment qu'un dispensaire
provisoire s'est installé à versailles
il ya des enfants quand on leur demande
si ça fait un peu ce que c'est d'aller
chez le médecin à l'hôpital et tout ça
il rattache beaucoup à des maladies très
graves
l'hôpital c'est la mort ou des choses
comme ça et là on leur montre que
finalement non à l'hôpital il ya plein
de gens qui sont soignés que toutes les
maladies ne sont pas graves qu'à
l'échelle médecin c'est pas grave pour
vaincre la peur plusieurs ateliers sont
organisés avec doudou même l'accès au
bloc opératoire se fait dans des
conditions presque réel organisé par
l'association au poème solidarité cette
matinée à l'hôpital des nounours a
également une portée pédagogique
apprendre à bien se brosser les dents ou
connaître par coeur les numéros
d'urgence les enfants apprennent en
s'amusant et en imaginant quand on leur
demande quelle doute
plein de choses qu'ils écoutent le coeur
doute tombé sous fin c'est vraiment
génial et nos feuilles sont vraiment à
la geôle imaginaire va être le plus fort
est ici nous arrive à se concentrer
suffisamment pour que ça fonctionne pas
et pour voir si le tout a bien
fonctionné les étudiants en médecine
passeront la semaine prochaine en classe
pour prendre des nouvelles et des
doudous a rendez vous pour les plus
grands cette fois et pour l'emploi à
noter dans vos agendas jeudi prochain le
vélodrome national sera le théâtre
durant dix heures d'un forum géant en
piste pour l'emploi pendant 10h 12h même
les participants vont pouvoir rencontrer
des employeurs mais aussi échanger avec
quelques 200 entreprises ou encore
s'informer sur des organismes de
formation les conférences de presse
avait lieu lundi au ski tubes à
guyancourt
aurélie rond étaient sur place 200
entreprises et près de 2000 offres
d'emploi voici ce qui vous attend le 29
mars prochain au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en piste pour
l'emploi proposera plusieurs espaces
dédiés au recrutement et à la formation
un événement qui se veut novateur c'est
un moment très pédagogique pour pour un
vendeur d'emplois mais en même temps
très activateur puisque il est
directement en rapport avec près de 200
entreprises qui sont à sa disposition
toute une journée pendant 12 heures avec
un taux de chômage de 7,2 pour cent au
dernier trimestre 2010 est le
département des yvelines affiche une
situation plutôt favorable par rapport
au reste de la france
néanmoins la part des demandeurs
d'emploi inscrits depuis plus de deux
ans continue à augmenter
première observateurs de cette tendance
pôle emploi qui sera présent lors de
l'événement
nous avons d'ailleurs des conseillers
pôle emploi qui animeront tout au long
de la journée nous aurons également des
conseillers pour l'emploi qui vont
accompagner leurs demandeurs d'emploi
notamment parmi les porteurs de
l'accompagnement intensive jeunes et qui
viendront effectivement accompagner les
publics tout au long de cette journée
vraiment enrichissante
le numérique tiendra également une place
importante lors de ce rendez-vous
information animation mais aussi job
dating attendent les futurs participants
qui s'inscrivent ils regardent et
l'intérêt c'est que les
et chefs d'entreprise vont regarder les
cv donc il ya déjà après une
présélection qui sera faite par rapport
à un certain nombre de critères ça c'est
important
et puis
il ya également les gens qui veulent
venir sans son inscription
objectif pour saint quentin en yvelines
que chacun puisse trouver le 29 mars un
emploi durable
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo retour
de l'information lundi à 18h sur
l'antenne de tv et 78 d'ici là restez
connectés et informés grâce à nos
applications tv 68 bon week-end à tous
et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]